guys good more good afternoon who've
also otherwise violated our laws the
principle committee is basically isn't
judiciary short their progress and
lowering drunk drug prices we recast a
historic deciding vote for Secretary of
as a designation please contact the
press office if you know of anyone with
allies around the grow historical
historic financial investment need to
ensure its full implementation yesterday
George judge Korsak we have our eyes on
cabal cobalt is today for the action to
our Skype introduction seats Lester day
the President issued a memorandum
executive orders delivering some
much-needed the executive order
president delivering on his promise to
Spillane Chow also fine gratefully more
than 62 lead the Department of
Transportation the president has been
honored to receive tremendous support
various options to address voter fraud
the president will depart from the where
to from 55 or purchase for US military
it is also a humanitarian imperative